un adolescente de 17 años es el menor
palestino número 20 que muere por fuego
israelí en lo que va de 2023 es decir
apenas cuatro meses según el Ministerio
de salud palestino El joven recibió un
disparo en la cabeza durante una nueva
redada del ejército israelí en el campo
de refugiados de acabar ya ver en el
área de Jericó las autoridades
sanitarias se confirmaron que otros seis
civiles resultaron heridos mientras que
otros tres palestinos fueron detenidos
este campamento ha sido objeto este año
de varias incursiones de las fuerzas
israelíes que alegan buscar a palestinos
sospechosos de participar en ataques
recientes bajo ese argumento desde hace
10 días entrar y salir de Jericó se ha
convertido en una Odisea por Los Fuertes
controles impuestos por el ejército de
Israel que ha generado bloqueos en el
tráfico durante varias horas los
palestinos del lugar denuncian que se
trata de un asedio sofocante que afecta
también al comercio de Jericó una ciudad
turística habitualmente más alejada de
la violencia Armada en así Jordania
ocupada pero no solo en Jericó se
produjeron redadas esta mañana tras
otras operaciones en yin Belén y Bay
Yala en ejército israelí reportó la
detención de al menos 17 personas y la
confiscación de armas la agencia de
noticias Palestina guapa por su parte
afirmó que un joven de 20 años resultó
herido en baychala y que los soldados
israelíes arrojaron gases lacrimógenos y
bombas aturdidoras cerca del hospital
gubernamental hechos sobre los que
Israel no brindó mayor información así
ya son 102 los palestinos fallecidos por
fuego israelí en 2023 mientras que 19
civiles han muerto del lado israelí en
ataques palestinos cifras que marcan el
inicio de año más sangriento desde la
segunda intifada